what's happening there reject nation
we're here today to watch brooklyn nine
nine season three episode seven and i
know some of you guys did not get the
memo yeah something went wrong with our
recording for episode six
and we're just gonna leave it at that
we're just gonna leave it at that yes
leaving it at that i'm sorry episode six
will not be going up isn't that right
john it was unusable footage for an
undisclosed reason that definitely had
nothing to do with yeah let's leave it
at that i apologize
and now it's a bummer because we really
enjoyed that
we really liked that episode i've been
sad for days and it's really a bummer
that we couldn't put it up
it has it's
just it won't
there's no fixing it episodes i remember
watching today it's just gotta get back
on track that's why we covered white
chicks instead for some reason we can't
just move on to next episode let's give
something else in return is a little
treat yeah special terry time and
episode seven the mattress leave a like
even if you're still mad at us
everyone's furious in the comments you
were itching for that truck for episode
six thanks to the boys and pepper
flopping outside of this town i won't
even tell you guys to go to our patreon
because we don't deserve it for this one
no isn't that right john
we never deserve patrons again
[Music]
scully has a mason jar full of lemonade
you called us in here to tell us that
before you see a mere five minutes ago
hitchcock introduced me to his new
goldfish who lives in oh an identical
mason jar oh this isn't gonna end well
there are two possible outcomes and
we're gonna bet on which one happens
first oh hitchcock put fish food in
scully's lemonade or will skelly drink
hitchcock's goldfish now you would think
that putting fish food into lemonade
hitchcock just drank his own fish what
[Music]
that's not not at all what i was
expecting
what a bunch of dumbasses you're two
minutes late i called all the emergency
rooms i know i went home from your place
to shower and i'm so tired that i fell
asleep while shaving my legs but we went
to bed so early property brothers was
over a tenth i mean
sex
[Music]
come on man yeah no i was up all night
because your dumb lumpy mattress is so
uncomfortable gina's listening yeah
where i have the solution to all of your
problems highly potent liquid speed oh
you're gonna love that stuff devon where
cops read the room
so what do you say should we take this
partnership from the sheets to the
streets oh our first case is a couple
why not oh this could be bad i just
discovered a new drug too it's called
your relationship and i'm high on it
what if he's really stupid terry this is
sam my little brother from brooklyn's
big brothers i think it's funny when she
calls me stupid no one cares stupid
screw you rosa
go home and do all your homework or i
will end you don't let rosa fool you
she's not that scary
she used to do ballet no way which gave
me the physical skills i need to
strangle you with my feet
actually sir i think we were kind of
hoping we could work the case together
oh are you two no longer smushing
booties
yes that's exactly how i was gonna fit
i don't put couples in the field
together but you are two of my best
detectives so i will allow it just don't
let any personal issues distract you
from it it's not gonna happen our only
close call was when jake didn't know who
will shorts was really
hmm
this is who you want to be with
in charge of our days and our nights
how am i supposed to
clown parked his clown car in captain
holt's spot and halfway into mine what a
clown sporty mm-hmm convertible yeah
that's the one oh i hate people who
drive sports cars hey captain get ready
to join him in the huff zone no no
stop gertie is our convertible i think
you'd like her she's a real peppy broad
oh my raymond hope may be on the title
but no man can own her spirit
you were saying something about some
creep
just some strangler that i was arrested
i was talking about some strangler that
i arrested well good job put the
paperwork on my desk now i have to go
find a strangler
that's what i was thinking
he said he'll point him out to us so you
approach on foot from the south and me
and devin will be in an unmarked car
here me and devin didn't you mean
devin and i oh god oh
i guess we're equally bad at grammar i'm
not bad at grammar i'm exhausted because
you refused to get a new mattress all
right why don't you just get a new back
we're not fighting we can totally work
together we're fine that was just sexy
workplace banter exactly i mean
mattresses are also sexy cause that's
where you do it grammar is system of
language involving syntax and semantics
also sexy
okay okay
just do it at work all right you're
almost to the corner you sure you're not
going to be spotted absolutely my cover
makes me invisible
[Laughter]
hey there's my dealer
jake great jacket six o'clock
excuse me sir do you have two minutes to
talk about the environment nypd yeah
he's headed for the building
i'll just stay here
[Music]
oh
moment of truth
amy's gonna bust him freeze jake he's
coming your way
oh
nice we're right on the mattress new
mattress this mattress looks just like
your mattress at home what no it doesn't
all right that settles it we're going
mattress shopping seriously oh this is
the best once we get it we'll have to
break it in oh i hear what you're saying
mattress trampoline wait no you were
talking about sex
trampoline titled my sex tape nice that
little dum-dum finished his homework
early isn't it rusted
maybe we could brew a part of knives we
like cincava tea and this spit it out
sam was brought in for shoplifting a
phone
i also have chamomile that might calm us
down rest in peace my boy what were you
thinking i made a mistake the phones
were just lying there and i didn't think
things through i'm sorry rosa uh we're
dealing with detective diaz now and she
is gonna make sure you rot in juvie for
the
[Laughter]
rest he's just a kid can't you just let
him off with a warning
sometimes being as tough as possible
doesn't lead to the best outcome this
isn't cagney calling lacey a poopy head
i'm not just gonna whoo
i screwed up big time
given your daily life experiences you're
gonna have to be more specific gertie
no
gertie
[Laughter]
i mean he parked in two spots it's kind
of his fault just have some b-bone boil
you know that's my smallest bone come on
no it's just a car he's not gonna be
that mad son of a dog oh no oh what did
he do to you gertie what did he do it
was an accident sir yes an accident the
buffoon's apology
the burns of polish they'll have to
custom mix the color because they no
longer make raspberry sherbet
they're all so beautiful
and they're all about to be tested
bouncy styles
oh here we go
oh
[ __ ]
my dream right here oh
holy moses that is much too much money
mattresses are expensive but they're an
investment it's gonna be in your life
for a long time true but it's also still
just a mattress you know it's a lot of
money to spend on a rectangle that's
filled with springs and goose hair you
know it's feathers i didn't
well to me it sounds like you're saying
i'm not worth it so i'm gonna go sleep
in my grown-up mattress that i bought
this century
oh
oh no
[Music]
my mattress accumulates value
you look well-rested yes because i slept
in my own bed
i was tossing and turning jake told me
about your fight
good job on the bus yesterday how was it
working together as a couple so good do
it again always do it that's weird look
at this the same two matches are missing
from both books third one on the bottom
row and fifth one on the top no one
would take matches out like that trust
me i smoked four cigarettes in college
one to completion
that's a code uh
i'll go get my pencil case
and it's a room number third floor fifth
room room 305 that's definitely it oh
great
great great santiago has solved it i
want you two to go undercover as a
couple oh no
apparently uh what was it um
smooshing booties great
and thank you for saying it that way it
made us both feel very comfortable
oh there's gonna be tons of mattresses
to the hotel before you decide what to
do with sam
there's someone i think you should talk
to
i tracked down your old ballet coach i
brought iran to remind you of the effect
a kind nurturing presence can have on a
young lie not a ballet coach miss miriam
was not nurturing at all all right ox
let's see what you've got eyes up
shoulders down
tough love works damn it nah terry
proved the wrong point
it's okay terry i should have never
tried to stand up to captain holt
oh i'm gonna just beg for mercy it's my
signature move
the charles oh
actually in the right in this stitch the
captain is being irrational but he's
about to learn himself a lesson right
about
now
[Laughter]
oh
what did you do to my cupcake
this is yours why on earth is your
cupcake on my channel
i can put it wherever i want this is
your fault now you have to buy me a new
cupcake this is outrageous you expect me
to avoid
huh
i see
your butt was charles's car yes the
chair is the parking space yes i get it
your office was the garage
[Laughter]
all right we're done here
you're a great captain
nailed it you know what your butt hates
making any sort of sacrifice for us
because it's not serious about this
relationship my butt is totally serious
i've made all kinds of changes i bought
orange soda for you
yay for the last time
orangina is not orange soda
i saw the text she sent you about
setting you up with some dude named gary
you read my texts it buzzed when you
were in the bathroom who doesn't bring
their phone with them into the bathroom
that's like the whole reason to go in
there
look the minute i tell her that i'm
dating someone she's gonna call me all
the time and ask me a million annoying
questions uh oh guess i'm just not
worth it boom use the thing you said to
me in a different argument in this
argument i win the art
[Laughter]
oh
no
you do have to admit it was a pretty
good point about orangina though
oh god guys
get it together your turn peralta thank
you santiago
oh before you say anything yes we
screwed up and yes you warned us and yes
i don't know where i'm going with this
but i do know this
i have reached the end of my sentence
[Laughter]
i can't believe you let a personal
argument derail your investigation i
would characterize it more as a
professional police disagreement i
listened to the tape oh no yeah well
then you know that it was a straight-up
crazy [ __ ] fight
when kevin and i first started dating he
taught at a small college upstate he
took the leap
and i'm so grateful that he did i only
regret that i didn't do it first the
train is your old mattress yeah the
car's new mattress i got it kevin is you
mm-hmm i'm santiago hey
i'll let him off with a warning
see the thing about miss miriam is
she made me a good dancer but she ruined
my childhood she was constantly writing
me about my posture and my technique and
my pink hair
never speak of that copy
i sure as hell don't want sam to quit
the big brother program because of me
this is totally how i thought this miss
miriam thing was gonna go
flawless terry plant absolutely i
thought you should know i just got
gertie back from the garage she looks as
good as new better even because after 12
years they finally got the annie linux
cassette out of the tape player i love
her
here's a check for the full amount you
don't owe me anything oh
i behaved poorly as gina made abundantly
clear oh speaking of you still owe me 14
for that cupcake
[Laughter]
sounds about right i want to change
mattresses for you that's the best thing
i've ever heard i'm sorry i didn't do it
sooner i think i was just
scared that you were gonna realize
you're way better than me you're
orangina and i'm orange soda are you
kidding me you're orangina
[Laughter]
i was scared too
i'm going to call my mom tonight
okay
jake jake look there's our guy oh
perfect timing submit order province i
don't know we're on the canadian website
click on the american flag yeah we'll do
this later let's go
oh man
you know that was a great episode
but
it is
such a downgrade compared to last week's
episode last week was a
truly great episode out of
10 10 out of 10 episode yeah a lot of
good bonding a lot of good character dev
you know i've only
almost teared up at one point
but this will
this will be fine this will do
that's it for today guys
tune in next week
where
there will be footage
[Music]
say goodbye
freak me i don't remember the rest of
the lyrics it's just something like
italy
that was me saying goodbye to the last
week's episode finally putting it to
rest single-tier drive so you can't see
it but there's a single teardrop that
left my eye you might have seen that in
last week's reaction we might have seen
it in last week's reaction
when rosa and holt are being emotional
together and crossing that bridge i
don't even want to think about it i
don't ever want to think about it
let's talk about this episode well john
what did you think be loud and clear
this was a great relatable episode why
actually because why because it's hard
couple and taking steps toward uh
further commitment towards each other
even what would you know about that
you know
just the ones learned from several
relationships i've been in over the
years oh no it's different though
you know it's different relationships
have changed as the last time you're in
a relationship that's right it's a whole
new age
it's all uh so absolutely 12 years for
you these things have changed 12 years a
bachelor
that's a long time i know you're a lucky
duck last time i dated i was 19.
you hear that ladies is my math okay i
don't know it's time to rescue john
that's right fix me dude
come on fix me save him yeah my craft's
my home
come on dump some money and then turn
flip me and sell me wait for more john
for better value later yo no you can be
the
thing to step inside his soul and go oh
no
oh i could change him change him change
john
that's right i can i can fix this mess i
can't get in and straighten him out i
can make him
streamline part of every healthy
relationship get in there
get in there ladies he needs a character
fix him he needs a nurse
um yeah so it's relatable
yeah from
you you've worked with girls
like friend friends that you dated
girlfriends that you dated
yes oh god what a nightmare especially
with the woman you've dated that's right
oh oh look out oh boy
oh boy that's right that's right bro wow
how are you still alive i would have
ended it
years ago not at any other job would
have seen life to have been like wow
where's the eject button from life and i
would have yes i would have easily hit
that button
wow
it's time to yeah just be done with it
all right
spoil that
believe it or not g believe it or not
yeah you'd be surprised
what the people around us were able to
endure this episode must have been very
relatable traumatic
i felt seen and attacked by this episode
olivia insisted we get a new mattress
and so we did
and you know what
i was like well i don't think we should
spend that much money
she was
wrong
the massager on the bed's been broken
for months and she keeps saying like
when are you gonna call them
to
have them come by to fix it and i'm
always like
you know you can't put that level of
responsibility on me
i'm too busy
uploading
watching brooklyn 99
being like jon can you do this
i got too much going on to make a five
minute phone call
to fix the bed well because it's not
just a five minute phone call then it's
figuring out a time for them to come by
and then it's an hour or two
waiting to see if they'll be on time and
then letting them in so you know lose
track of them because what if they're
stealing from you and after four months
really it's olivia's responsibility
that's right she's gotta realize that
i'm not gonna do it so really the blame
goes to her
she should have just brought a mattress
with her when she got it thank god for
jaden and amber we can now blame the
woman that's right everything finally
falls at reversing finally it's never
been that way that's right never
according to many people it's never been
that way i finally reversed the effects
of the side effects of feminism um
so
yes anyway john you're telling me about
these crazy
demeaning
hookers you
you've been with yeah all of them
correct and um so you relate with that
perfect checkpoint one yeah done
learning to be affectionate sometimes
that action
you know sometimes that's the thing is
like that's why it's important to learn
to be vulnerable because a lot of the
time you know being scared or being hurt
comes out in other ways
could come out in pure violence
like don't give me a wrong
what you had to do
to put those exes in their place
in public from time to time
believe me
i get it now when we're around other
people am i going to be like john you
maybe shouldn't treat them that way of
course i'm just saving face
um
but at the time i was like i can't blame
a guy man
i felt very supportive yeah i just just
say no i only had to disagree with it
because there were
there were other people there were yeah
there were girls i had to
placate to
fragility yeah yeah the snowflakes just
like over sensitivity
blue hair you know snowflakes out there
now they
can be
uh
i know how they can be um i don't even
like to use the word they though i
prefer uh she or him that's it oh we're
talking about a different subject now
i'm just throwing everything terribly i
mean i feel like that's all good
um
so yes
what else happened in this oh hey i mean
captain holt owned up when he was being
unreasonable even though he is the boss
he's in the power position the amount of
times john in our dynamic
has gotten mad at me and had to
apologize for getting mad at me
is ridiculous it's too many times
it's definitely not usually the other
way around
consistently
i gotta rage i gotta reach out you know
consistently
having
to apologize for
be i'm always the boyle i fly off he's
always the halt
yes
you know i have assisted i i appreciate
it it's the dynamic between us you're
the cameras puppy dog energy
as the boyle of this house and
frankly john um
i i think that
well i deserve it
fair enough
who am i aren't you
who am i to argue you know
yes get get get competent
you know
and don't park over the line
yeah no matter how special
and valuable
your [ __ ] is you know
and then uh rosa learning about tough
love and knowing that tough love can
often be too tough tough love is a fine
line you can push someone away
or break their investment
i gotta tell you
no one knows how to be on the receiving
end better
than the way john gives me tough love
that's right man constantly i only do it
because i want to bring the best out of
you constantly
so deep buried in there oh i'm just like
i gotta go hard [ __ ] man john's
john's right
tough enough
step up today
it's not tough enough hey coach
give me a bat and a helmet it's time for
me to take that swing it's usually what
i say once a month that's right
when i get a case of the tough loves
that's right it's like put me in coach i
can prove it i can prove it myself yeah
that's what happens here man and every
time
you know you don't question you don't
worry about expectations
of foods
buffoons and followers apologies
the great responses
sarcasm the cowards lie there's a lie oh
oh yeah i'm gonna use that is so funny
or or that will be used against me
the buffoons apology
heard someone in the sauna the other day
and say
if you become a mathematician
to keep
your problems in your life they're
talking about drugs if you become a
mathematician
to keep your problems in your life ah
what was it it was so good my eyes were
closed at the time so i didn't see his
face and i was like oh i should remember
that trying to remember right here on
camera with you guys
if you become a mathematician
oh to keep justifying your bad
if you become a mathematician to keep
doing your bad habits then you've got a
real problem
interest i think that's what he said
okay about that mathematician
in that like
you have to become increasingly adept at
like complex
emotional equations or is it what the
[ __ ] you're getting so carried away to
the point where your
bad habits are expensive but you're just
like if you're someone who's like i
spend like a thousand dollars on weed a
month maybe you shouldn't be smoking
that much weed
there are people who do that i believe
and absolutely and it's like
like oh no i gotta make these i gotta
make my rent i'm struggling with money
but i also gotta get my marijuana
yeah it makes a lot of sense
yeah it's not a more profound i don't
think i'm saying it right
something that he said it might never
specifically put it i was like that's a
good life lesson it'll come to you in a
dream when you go to sleep on your nice
mattress
when i make that call
it's good it's good it's good yeah yeah
at the point where you have to develop
skills to maintain this one habits
affecting all your other life things
yeah and maybe you're in the wrong line
of business
maybe you you put your energies in the
wrong place
yes
anyway yeah funny episode well done
really funny everyone's great as usual
what more can you say right didn't
expect hitchcock to eat the the fish
why it's totally what i expected i
didn't expect it happened the way it
happened you're smarter with the comedy
than i am that's why
we took a comedy test too greg passed it
and i failed it i did i paid 300 for it
online you paid 300
i paid a thousand
well if you become a mathematician
no better you should have known better
the joke is on me ladies and gentlemen
that's what we call a call back miss it
is
call back let's get one more in before
the video is done ah yes rule of three
three golf x is what it takes otherwise
it doesn't count
all right guys
it's time for us to depart we'll see you
soon